the reigning world Fisher random chess
champion Hikaru Nakamura took on the
previous Champion Wesley so in the
semi-finals of the chess.com Global
Chess Championship
these Titans of U.S chess are two of the
most difficult chess players to beat in
the world and they each proved their
resilience over the board with a pair of
accurately played draws to open the
match and if black plays one more
natural move King it didn't happen but
there were some ways for black to get in
trouble but Bishop draw and that's
exactly what we expected don't worry
you'll never get in trouble for talking
chess but these two players they have no
distance between them no separation can
be found in this match of slight
advantages for West End Game one hikar
in game two but we have two draws the
players walk away from the playing Hall
get a little rest things heated up in a
marathon fight in game three in an even
night end game Nakamura had slightly
more chances to press so and he
leveraged every opportunity available
the game was dead equal until after move
100 when so finally cracked and allowed
Hikaru to win a pawn Knight G7 he's
plundered it uh-oh he's blundered it uh
oh oh he's plundered it but it's still
probably a draw oh my gosh this is
insane Hikaru was ready to snap up his
well-earned point but then so's King
activated and posed real problems with
an error on move 119 Hikaru returned the
pawn and the position reverted to
equality B5 whoa now Knight D2 without
92 Knight D2 and Knight F1 check is an
immediate drop of will mostly find it
he's got 18 seconds plays Knight E3 yeah
that's a draw Knight takes G4 is
possible the game ultimately lasted an
insane 134 moves before peace was
finally forced with a repetition okay
but like this game as they draw for the
third time really does kind of show that
you could work that hard you can still
make a draw one and a half one and a
half both players they're not even
leaving the chairs Wesley's like I can't
believe I just played two games in one I
I can't believe it either you can see
the frustration as icaro pulls his
headphones off he has incredibly high
standards for himself he was expecting
himself to win that end game yeah
probably from the very beginning having
suffered for so long in game three one
might have expected so to be less
ambitious in the final game of the day
but he came out strong quickly claiming
a major Edge out of the opening and
eventually expanding with F4 I don't
think he's happy though he's not bobbing
his head any longer you can see the sort
of consternation on his family both
players are just locked in concentration
Hikaru made the radical decision to
sacrifice The Exchange and while
stockfish did not like it and believed
so was winning hikaru's position was
very hard to break down with the
excellent moves 37 Knight to F3 and then
44 Rook takes B4 Hikaru forced a
repetition and day one concluded with
the match still deadlocked a draw is
agreed by repetition what a game what a
game yeah again we have two draws I know
we were calculating some crazy stuff
with Nike because if you take it then
the queen captures and forks the Rooks
yeah we were calculating this solid
draws began day two in games five and
six and they set up a massive game seven
as Hikaru pushed hard to leverage his
last game with the white pieces so
sacked upon but he got the bishop here
in a very open position Anything could
happen as time trouble set in so turn
the advantage to his side of the board
pushing Hikaru to sacrifice an exchange
out of clear discomfort he goes for a
sacrifice and I think that speaks to the
fact he was not enjoying his position as
does like his body language Hikaru began
shaking his head and he only increased
the head shakes as the game progressed
Hikaru is famously good with the knights
and he performed magic with them as he
even sacrificed a rook for a moment to
eliminate so's past death Pawn but so
claimed a new past a pawn in return and
I don't know how to evaluate this
position he's gonna have a past tape on
this has to be winning my instincts say
this has got to be winning he's got a
pass Pawn that the king cannot touch
right the Knight has to bring itself to
the B file and act as a shield so the
king can walk over after some thought
hikara resigned with one game remaining
Wesley so now had the first lead of the
match he resigns and Wesley wins with
the resignation and I mean this is
probably dead in the water but that was
still an early resignation wait we know
how resilient 94. actually I think igoro
missed that he could go 94. we're gonna
wait and watch the reactions on camera
yeah I think Hikaru could have continued
the fight there needing to win with
black Hikaru attempted an unorthodox
King's Indian setup but so responded
with the excellent 65 and 8 G4 accepting
the challenge with these Pawn thrusts
and playing for a draw from a position
of great strength E6 may be still
available but look that knife is getting
permanently trapped on the side of the
board with G4 and that is such a
thematic that's just a nasty move to
face it covers the F5 Square so is in
fact close to a win on move 24 when he
went for the flashy Rook to d8 this move
one hikaru's Queen but it also gave
Hikaru the best position he had had in
the entire game exactly do not whoa whoa
Rook to D.A oh my God what a move what a
move I don't know how good that is but
I'll tell you I love the look of it
Daniel that is just a flashy move it is
but it's not good it is but it's not
good he wins the queen that was the idea
to follow up with Knight C6 he could
have also started with Knight C6 would
have been the same exact thing he's won
the queen but but but Hikaru has a rook
and a knight he's gotten the Knight onto
C5 and he's entrenched it on that square
it's a great night in a few moves Hikaru
even had the better practical position
and he began to apply pressure using
every second on the clock and every
maneuver to his Advantage Rook to E7
defending it it just doesn't feel
comfortable The Way Wesley has used his
Queen to attack your car response has
been so impressive I'd also point to the
move Bishop D5 that could combine with
Quincy and just win the game outright
that's right Bishop C6 Queen G8 also
might tie black down the the defense of
that Knight on E8 so much that you just
can't move in order to win yeah and
Bishop B5 Hikaru again he's trying to
find that Arrangement where he's
defending everything and you know
exerting pressure on Wesley's position
but that's such a tall order I feel like
you can do one or the other but can he
find a way to do both moves are going to
be coming in Rapid Fire here as this is
the mark of a strong player can you
coordinate three pieces that are often
hanging all at once and they are hanging
Wesley brings his Bishop back to D3 his
King all the way back to D1 Hikaru keeps
drawing I think he's making some
progress now the Knight moves to D5
Amman there's so many Forks here get the
queen and king get it out of there in
like a six seconds yeah get them far
away from each other we need a long-term
release two seconds Bishop E4 he's gotta
move oh my God Queen down to C8
something what's going on here Knight F4
I'm so scared of a fork here and with
four seconds this is the worst case
scenario by Wesley and it's coincided
with a peak of activity of hikaru's
pieces Bishop F6 this is exactly where
he wants the game in a Time scramble
four seconds for Wesley and he's got 20.
he's got enough time to figure out a
tactic or a fork 20 seconds for Hikaru
is five hours for somebody else the
King's zigzagging and Meandering its way
between box pieces and chasing the
Knight away from C3 that's right if it
goes back to D5 we might see maybe
bishop C4 it takes the pawn
because now the Queen's gonna go to C6
and if you lose the C7 Pawn you
basically lose your winning chances
that's right we could see Bishop to G6
you want to be far away from a night
check so diagonal is great now Queen C6
runs into Rook C5 so maybe Slide the
queen all the way to over to eight and
he does Queen G8 is a you know kind of a
backdoor move instead he backdoors it to
C6 the Knight moves back to D7 again
Rook C5 is a huge problem Wesley might
have to move his King though this is
getting very good for hikar he might
even try Bishop to E5 to defense C7
hikar just keeping the tension and
keeping the tension he's got 50 moves
before the 50 movable comes into effect
that's what he wants but he's lost the
F7 Pawn that was not as planned Bishop
oh no this might signify the end if he
car was winning chances Knight to E5 is
he not getting mated there and the King
sliding back to be one look how expertly
how deftly Wesley sidesteps all the
forks and now the Knight as passive as
it's ever been and be careful not to
lose your Rook to a fork oh Bishop C6 is
coming now Wesley might find out be
playing for a win yep that's right but
he doesn't even need to win trust me if
there's a draw at the table his hand is
grabbing that yeah one second now for
Hikaru he's just trying to prevent them
The Rook has been hung by Hikaru and
he's up and he is out of the playing
Hall oh my God what a finale oh my
goodness that was the end of his chances
there he needed that Rook but so hard to
keep it Daniel with the queen having
checks all over the open board Hikaru
did everything within his power and
everything not within his powers the
fact that he got this to a Time scramble
as the incredulous smile of relief by
Wesley so so advances to the cgc finals
where he will play Nihao sarin for the
200 000 first place prize as a bonus
prize so LeapFrog takaro in the fide
rapid ratings and he is now ranked
fourth in the world
thank you
[Music]